margarit president Trump's abrupt
decision to declare Israel's permanent
ownership of the disputed Golan Heights
is provoking international condemnation
the president upended more than five
decades of US policy with his call on
Twitter yesterday saying it was time
Israel seized that territory from Syria
in the 67 war so how's the president's
announcement being received well with
that condemnation from the international
community but it is so popular in Israel
where his friend Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu is really fighting for
survival in an election that's going to
be held just 18 days from now Netanyahu
has really sought to capitalize on his
close relationship with the president
even as you see there featuring him in
campaign ads the Prime Minister is under
a lot of pressure he faces a possible
criminal indictment on charges of
bribery and corruption so this boost
helps him he called the president
yesterday and said thank you now the
president in an interview has said it
was not deliberately meant for political
reasons but here in the u.s. even
Republican lawmakers of evangelical
Christians argue this is all gonna help
Israel's security here's the thing
nothing's changing on the ground
thousands of Syrians live there the UN
has been there policing it Israel's been
in control of it since 1981 when they
annex this territory which is why it is
considered illegal under international
law so there's a lot of concern among
diplomats that this sets a very
dangerous precedent because it allows a
country and recognizes its ability to
seize territory through military force
so that sends a signal to countries like
Russia
hey maybe by creating facts on the
ground you can legitimize your military
interventions all right Margaret thanks